tom Fitton of judicial watch your new
book is called clean house why why did
you call it that well because we're
looking forward I know there's been a
lot of concern about the corruption here
in Washington DC during the Bush Obama
era because I think that's the way to
think about it in some respects and that
people think the system is broken and
there's this inherent corruption and
almost everything the federal government
does and I tend to share that point of
view and I think our success points our
way forward
that there is a way of holding the
government to account and little old
judicial watch is able to have these
successes in terms of getting government
information and getting changes in the
way government operates or certain the
way politicians operate and it's not all
bad and there are certain reforms and
ways of approaching discussions of
public policy in Washington that it
ought to be thought about and we try to
raise that in a forward-looking way you
know what struck me about working on the
book is how irrelevant the election was
to what we were doing and and what was
going to happen we thought or what
should happen over the next few years I
want to show you some video of you march
4th 1995 appearing on our call-in show
let's watch this is you pick up the
morning papers what stands out well an
interesting piece here on on Hillary
Clinton's I guess new role as a foreign
policy representative for the United
States we have been told that Hillary
would take less of a forward role in
major policy issues that she would stick
to the traditional first lady role in
terms of taking issues I think she was
talking about hunger for children and
breast cancer and such and well turns
out that President Clinton decided he
doesn't have enough time to go to
Pakistan he doesn't have enough time to
go to India he's gonna send his wife
Hillary Clinton 21 years later you're
still talking about Hillary Clinton that
was national empowerment television days
can you tell us why you would be talking
about her then
and what were you doing I was even
before I came to Judicial Watch in 1998
I was a I was a analyst for national
Palmer television which was founded by
Paul Warwick and was almost a precursor
to Fox in some respects and Newt
Gingrich had a TV show on it even
Arianna Huffington of all people had a
TV show on it and I was one of the
20-something analysts that mr. Wyrick
who has since passed away had brought on
to kind of bring a different perspective
to discussions about politics it's a it
seems like a different person at least
physically but boy I still think the
same way in some respects you were how
long back in 1995 out of George
Washington University oh not that long
or five six years and where did you get
your entrance I mean Paul Wyrick is a
well-known conservative where did you
get your conservative news life you know
my folks have been conservatives you
know I just was grown up around the
issues generally but working in the
movement and I began working for Morton
Blackwell who's a well-known
conservative activist who specializes in
training young people on how to be
active irrespective of party but he
wants conservatives to know how to
figure out how to win you know you kind
of learn about policy the longer you're
here and how it's made and you come in
as a younger person thinking well just
because someone's a Republican they
might be right or just because someone's
a Democrat they might be wrong you learn
that you learn that's not the case if
the policy issues are more nuanced not
necessarily conservative versus liberal
but you have to realize that not all
Republicans are in it for the right
reasons and that all Democrats are in it
for the right or even wrong reasons and
I think the longer been a traditional
watch I recognize that too often the
partisans for either side defend their
side no matter what they do and that is
got to stop and I think that's why
Americans are so disaffected with
Congress I don't think they were worried
that Congress can't isn't doing enough I
think they just think it's corrupt no
matter which party is running it
I have a quote from you and and this
will not surprise you the quote is the
government does not want you to know
what they are doing that's a broad
statement what do you mean by the
government well the federal government
isn't terribly interested in complying
with the key federal law out there it's
called the Freedom of Information Act
it's been around since the late 60s and
they don't like telling you what they're
up to they don't like giving you the
details you see that most apparently
with mrs. Clinton taking all of her
emails with her when she left the State
Department and not telling the American
people that all that government material
was in her system and not sharing it as
she should have under the law but in our
experience at Judicial Watch the
government's doing more than ever and is
less interested than ever in sharing
what they're doing with the American
people or feel like they don't feel like
there should be accountable you have the
agencies that we sue we're often suing
just to be told yes or no just to get an
answer to our request for information as
opposed to just fighting over what
they're giving us or what they're
withholding and of course the we note in
the book is the terms of a way forward
the Freedom of Information Act only
applies to the executive branch doesn't
apply to Congress it doesn't apply to
the judiciary so and you say in your
book it doesn't apply that white house
and the White House has been walled off
from a lot of the transparency law at
least the FOIA that requires responses
within 20 days the presidential Records
Act some will make those records
available you know in the Chelsea
Clinton administration but you have to
wait a long time for that to happen how
much of the going back to your quote the
government does not want you to know
what they're doing when you say the
government how much of that is the top
level the political appointees versus
the government bureaucrats that have a
full-time job for 30 years
well the bureaucrats process the FOIA is
I think in the ordinary course typically
and the delaying comes from either
politicized bureaucrats and senior
levels or the Schedule C appointees the
political appointees the you know the
cabinet heads in there
and their immediate staff they tend the
slow walk the release of information and
that's usually responsible for the
delays in our experience if you are
going to give an award to any government
agency or a person that you've worked
with over the last what 1998 to develop
a Judicial Watch for responding to the
Freedom of Information Act possibly but
who would it be oh that's a good
question you know the State Department
used to be pretty darn good at the
Freedom of Information Act responses
when prior to mrs. Clinton coming into
office how do you know that did you
notice a difference well they were
always slow but they were thorough and
professional in their responses and and
it was a testament really to the high
quality of the personnel at the State
Department but since then it's low all
bets are off and you know and and you're
grading on a curve when you give an
award to transparency you know the worst
agency in some respects you know the
State Department is terrible but every
withholding every stalling tactic is
defended by the Department of Justice
and they're charged with enforcing the
rule of law and they defend the
lawlessness on FOIA to the hilt and you
asked Justice Department for documents
directly and they're about as bad as it
can get in terms of unwillingness to
provide information bring us up to date
on your organization how many people
work there now a little less than 50
people working there how much money will
you spend in the counter year 2016 our
budget this year is around thirty four
million dollars you said on this network
a few weeks ago that if you have some
four hundred thousand contributors
individuals do you still have the
big-ticket items that come from people
like Richard Mellon Scaife
who's no longer he's deceased well his
foundations has been public they
publicly disclose their donations to us
and they do support us you know we don't
have the type of donors that some other
groups have where we have one or two or
just a few donors that could make or
break them if they stopped giving so
we've been blessed for wide
widespread support obviously we have
some donors who are more generous than
others given their capacities but we're
in a wonderful situation in terms of
just this grassroots army behind us that
wants us to get to the bottom of what
the open is up to I want to show you a
picture Lee over here on the screen of
it it's around the time of the Richard
Mellon Scaife death and it's a picture
of Chris ruddy who runs news max out of
Florida who used to write for the his
the newspaper that Richard Mellon Scaife
owned it's explain this bizarre okay I
mean if people outside of here see
Richard Mellon Scaife funded the
Arkansas project the Clinton project in
Arkansas with David Brock of all things
who went after Bill Clinton and here's
Bill Clinton showing up giving a eulogy
at Richard Mellon Scaife funeral help us
out
I think you'd actually asked Chris about
how that worked he's a friend of mine
and it's astonishing that that he was
able to result that this set you had he
had this were approach moment with the
with mr. Clinton I think he thought
highly of the foundation and its efforts
and at least this publicly what he said
and then he supported them but it's you
know strange bedfellows over time people
change my view is the Clintons never
changed their stripes and we're kind of
seeing evidence of that let me use the
word cynicism in public again watches
this process and here's Richard Mellon
Scaife whose multi-millionaire
billionaire or whatever giving money to
try to wipe out Bill Clinton back in the
90s with David Brock writing for
conservative publication the American
Spectator but now David Fox
totally on the other side paying money
to Sidney Blumenthal who you know about
because you have gotten some of these
emails published is there any reason how
I explained trying to figure this out
for the public well you know the
Clintons think it's always about them
and it isn't it you know escapes money
is given in a way my understanding is
that he gives it to groups and the
groups do a variety of things Judicial
Watch sued Dick Cheney
we got money from dick Scafe to sue dick
cheney how do you how do you incorporate
that you incorporate you figure that the
way it works is that you have
philanthropists who like the mission of
organizations and support that mission
with donations and sometimes they're
people who don't like the results of the
activities of those organizations like
Bill or Hillary Clinton and they think
well of course it's a vast right-wing
conspiracy against me and you know the
Scafe clinton relationship that
developed over the years shows that it
wasn't that that wasn't the case i mean
dicks gate became friendly with mister
clinton while continuing to support
judicial watch that was significant was
always critical of the clinton ethic and
you know i recall back in 2009 we were
warning about what the problems were
going to be with bringing mrs. clinton
into the obama administration and you
know maybe president obama did agree he
even paid attention to us thought it was
crocodile tears but i knew these uh
these Clinton scandals where all of a
sudden going to become Obama scandals
over the long term so he's one of those
ironies of organizations in this town if
mrs. Clinton's elected president isn't
that a positive for Judicial Watch which
will raise a lot more money to try to
expose what she does well I think our
work is going to be significant as a
result in people you know should be
supporting us no matter who's elected
president I think the Clinton email
scale for instance isn't going it'll go
away no matter who's elected and if mrs.
Clinton thinks there'll be no criminal
investigation or no pressure for
additional investigations issues
President or anyone thinks that that
pressure will be eliminated or there'll
be no possibility of that happening if
she's elected they don't know the way
the process works in fact there may be
increased pressure for a criminal
investigation at least a special
prosecutor or an independent
investigation certainly over the Clinton
Foundation issues if she's elected and
these issues aren't going away whether
mr. Trump is elected or whether mrs.
Clinton is elected and and those
Republicans who think corruption goes
away even if your candidate is put in
you know we learned that from the Bush
administration President Bush came into
office and said well you know I'm not
so why would anyone his people say
question us and there's plenty good
reason the question a government that
spends as much money as it does with all
the temptations of corruption that Saran
that that are that arise from all that
money I am in my hand sounds dramatic
and I maintain 30th 2016 released from
judicial watch the headline is Judicial
Watch submits email questions to Hillary
Clinton written answers under oath do
September the 29th and you have 25
questions here what is this well this is
discovery it's called it's evidence
gathering in federal court and on one of
our cases we asked for information about
the special government employee status
of human Abidine her then team deputy
chief of staff for a period of time she
was working at the State Department at
the Clinton Foundation and another
Clinton concern called Tadeo and
obviously how did the heck did that
happen so we asked for government
documents on that and we got some
documents that they told us they looked
everywhere they could can we shut the
case down then the email story erupted
the case was reopened which was
extraordinary and the court in that case
judge Sullivan was interested in trying
to figure out why was this system set up
the way it was that it's wart the
Freedom of Information Act and you know
what was mrs. Clinton thinking so he
granted us some discovery there and of
course we want to make sure all the
records that she took were searched as
they should have been so he granted us
some discovery deposed Abidine we
deposed mrs. Cheryl Mills or chief of
staff and top officials of the State
Department and Bryan Pagliano the
Clinton it--they official who took the
fifth took the fifth year and then we
thought it was you know we couldn't get
the answers we thought necessary for the
courts discovery so we asked the court
that deposed mrs. Clinton in person and
he said no it's too onerous and there's
something less onerous that you can do
which is to submit questions that you'll
have to respond to an oath under writing
and those are the questions is that
reading your book and you mentioned a
lot of judges that intrigued me so I
went on the line and found
and then I've got four judges here who
appointed them because you you basically
have used the judicial system are they
the court system in order to break some
of this stuff open but I want to put up
on the screen again the list and you can
see it there it's Judge Rudolph
Contreras he was an Obama appointee
Colleen or Colleen Kohler Kelly a
Clinton appointee judge Emmett Sullivan
you just mentioned him he's a Clinton
appointee and Royce Lamberth was a
reagan appointee the reason I bring this
up is I know we're in the weeds a little
bit but you have to go to these judges
and what does it say that a lot of these
three out of the four judges were
appointed by Democrats but they have
looked favorably on what you're doing
yeah we we have to put a put forward a
legal case for the relief we're seeking
either to get the documents to force the
government to give them more quickly
than they want to give them we were
before I think of an Obama appointee the
other day who questioned why the State
Department said they needed 30 days to
review 30 documents that they found in
new Clinton emails that were just turned
over to them by the FBI so you know the
rule of law still works and you know we
complain a lot about what goes on in
Washington but what a what a wonderful
system we have that Judicial Watch and
doesn't matter of your politics where
we're one nonprofit group and we go into
court and we're on equal footing in many
respects with the federal government and
the powers they have are awesome the
resources they have are infinite all the
lawyers they can all the lawyers they
need and they still are held to account
to our requests under law and it's a
wonderful precious right we have because
I can tell you that there's no other
country in the world where that is
possible do you the extent it's
available here in the United States
exactly nowhere else have you ever seen
politics from a judge in this town and
these judges are all here in Washington
all on the district court here well you
know I think it's more prudence you know
some judges are hesitant about bringing
in high-level politicians because the
judiciary in politics is something they
may not
like the the greater concern is I think
the deference that federal judge has
showed to the federal government so
despite this equal footing we have the
government has an outsized they're given
too much deference too often by the
federal government by the federal judges
on transparency issues with the Clinton
admitted the Clinton email scandal that
you know all the goodwill they've had in
the past the agency has had a certainly
the State Department has been dissipated
so that deference is lessening but it's
still there if the government comes in
and makes the representation even though
we think it's bunk it's just in it's
just I think engrained than the judges
DNA to take the government at its word
too often but that's changing slowly
especially since the gamesmanship we've
had with the Obama administration and
mrs. Clinton on emails have you been in
the room when Huma Abedin and Cheryl
Mills and Bryan Pagano were deposed by
your organization I was there for
Abedini Mills deposition I missed
Pagliano step position but I was there
for we had seven depositions I was there
for six of them how do you see in these
people when you're sitting there is it
done behind closed doors and has it done
with no recording and their public
recordings the judge in this case
decided that the videotape of the
depositions are going to remain under
seal for at least for now but the
transcripts are available they're a
bunch of lawyers we have a few lawyers
who only one lawyer asks the questions
and the government has typically three
or four lawyers there and and the
individual that especially the third
parties who aren't working for the
government anymore they bring in their
own attorneys so someone like Cheryl
Mills and you Mohammed Dean will have
one or two attorneys in there there
personally as well so there are six or
seven lawyers on the other side and you
know we have lawyers there and I'm
attending as a as a client I'm not a
lawyer as a principal though I mean as
the principal sitting at the table home
Abba Dean or Cheryl Mills are they
nervous it's an intense situation you
don't want to be deposed in a federal
court proceeding where do you do it you
do it generally in law offices you
do it a judicial watch or at the Justice
Department or at the Law Offices of the
attorneys in a case of Abidine or Mills
these might go over to their attorneys
offices and it's in a conference room
and a non-disruptive Lee nondescript
location and it's interesting they're
regular people of many respects they're
cordial you know contrary to what their
political enemies think these people
aren't in the positions they are because
they're terrible people and they're mean
to everybody you know they're usually
friendly and smart and cordial so you'd
be surprised how pleasant at least on
the surface the interactions are so go
back to this 25 questions that you're
going to that you've asked Hillary
Clinton in print how does something like
this come together well let me let me
just find a question and read it so the
audience gonna and can you find these
all online yeah they're all on our
website that Judicial Watch dot org it's
a matter of fact that one on Facebook
the other day and and read them all just
so people could see them on Facebook or
via via video it's another way of
educating you did that yeah here's know
I guess it word out about them here's
number six were you ever advised caution
door warned was it ever suggested or did
you ever participate in any
communications conversation or meeting
in which it was discussed that your use
of Clinton mail.com email account to
conduct official State Department
business conflicted with or violated
federal record-keeping laws did you
write these I didn't write them the
lawyers wrote them here's a number eight
after President Obama nominated US
Secretary of State and during your
tenure as Secretary did you expect the
State Department to receive FOIA
requests for or concerning your email
yeah
what's they what do you hope to get out
of it we're getting to these are our
records when you're a government
official our meaning our meaning the
taxpayers records and what you're a
government official even if you're
writing on your supposedly personal
email account you're doing government
business you're creating a record that
you don't own
that we own and you're keeping them away
from the American people by not telling
them about it despite warnings despite
your your own knowledge that the laws
apply you're doing something gravely
wrong and you know what purpose is it
that you don't have consent of the
government if we don't know what the
government is up to and mrs. Clinton
didn't want us to know what she was up
to she didn't want these emails ever
coming out and if they were to come out
you would have had to go through her
lawyer who in concert with mrs. Clinton
deleted half of them and only for the
efforts of the FBI did they get who
knows how many undeleted well you know
there's been I can't think of a more
significant assault on the premise and
the operation of the Freedom of
Information Act as mrs. Clinton's
decision-making related to her emails
the fella behind the Freedom of
Information Act Congressman John Moss a
Democrat from California back in the 60s
had what in mind what was moving him and
was there a resistance I remember
reading a Lyndon Johnson wasn't
particularly happy with this Antonin
Scalia wasn't particularly happy with it
say you got one on one side one on the
other yeah you know the conservative
some conservatives constitutional types
don't like the Freedom of Information
Act because it impinges too much on the
decision-making of the executive branch
and makes them answerable to the other
branches in ways that are not
appropriate under the separation of
powers but you could see in Johnson's
opposition it was a he's a prank he was
a pragmatic politician so he knew what
he was up to and he didn't want people
prying and that's why he didn't like it
well go to the emails when take your
pick Ronald Reagan George Herbert Walker
Bush George W Bush Bill Clinton the
current president do they have access to
the emails when they write their books
and get 14 million dollar advances and
we don't you know I think they do I
think they do I think they I mean mrs.
Clinton got 14 million dollars
reportedly when she wrote her book after
she was in the State Department yeah and
we asked her about her use of the emails
after she left office and that's a good
question
I have it in my head they have access to
them but it intersects with the National
Archives who takes control of the
presidential records typically the
records are processed and only release
with the approval of the President or
the president has a chance at issue has
a chance to chime in as to whether it's
appropriate to release but as you know
George W Bush put the clamps on the
presidential papers when he came in and
it was lifted then by Barack Obama but
people now including journalists suggest
that Barack Obama has one of the least
transparent administrations yeah it's a
complicated issue so I'm hesitant to
kind of do off-the-cuff analysis of the
presidential Records Act but there are
significant delays in the release of
Records and just when you think the
records are supposed to be released for
instance I think it's 12 years after the
president leaves office the records are
supposed to be begin to be released and
we're still getting Clinton Records that
they have in process we're being alerted
well we finally process the processes
process them you know six eight years
later what are they so worried about
who's the Veii the politician that
doesn't want the stuff out what are they
worried what is it that we're gonna
learn that we shouldn't know and if
that's the case why isn't the Congress
doing a better job of getting this
information well you know I think
there's this idea in Washington that the
cover-up force in the crime and I don't
know if I buy that usually there's a
crime the cover-up or misconduct to
cover-up and there's something
politically inconvenient or embarrassing
however trite it may be in the greater
scheme of things I mrs. Clinton I still
go back to you know I remember this
happening a people should verify but
James Carville a few weeks shortly after
the email scandal broke last year he
said I tell you why mrs. Clinton didn't
want these emails you know didn't do the
proper thing on the emails didn't say it
like that but he said because she didn't
want louie gohmert going through all our
emails louie gohmert being the
republican republican texas congressman
known as a strong conservative and
that's that to me is so typical Clinton
that she did not want
her perceived political enemies looking
at her emails and the law was
inconsequential in terms of that final
goal for which was of power you know
related to her power and and the
government agencies don't believe
they're answerable to the American
people I don't think philosophically
they believe they are accountable
Congress is complicit because they're
not they spend the money and then
practically speaking don't pursue
oversight of how that money's spent and
some ways it's impossible given the
amounts at issue you write a check for a
trillion dollars over the after three
days of debate I mean what what human
institution can track that money it's to
me if you want a police Washington you
need to severely curtail the amount of
money it's spending because it's just
too much money of the track what great
would you give this for public and
Congress both the house in the Senate
for going after this kind of information
that you're going after it's an F
absolute FY they haven't gone after it
why aren't they I don't think they see
corruption and scandal and oversight as
political winners and to the degree they
talk about it they use it as a way to
keep their political opponents off
kilter but that's the limited purpose
they're not interested in in true
accountability you I think it's fair and
you can correct us you learned at the
elbow of a couple of people in this town
that have been very visible over the
years are both deceased I first want to
show you this video of a man you
mentioned earlier Paul Wyrick Paul Irish
appearing here in 2005 and they keep
died in 2008 and he started the Heritage
Foundation among other places let's
watch this I'd like to think that the
network that I found at any T was the
precursor to to Fox News but that
operation demonstrated that there was a
market for right-of-center programming
if you will and I am told that a lot of
the people who are involved with Fox
were watching that Network when it was
on why didn't a tional empower
television make it and what did you
learn from Paul Ari I don't know why any
TJ don't make it I think you you
probably know better than I do the the
business side of networks getting on to
cable systems and how that happens and
there's a significant financial hurdle
to getting on to the systems and
oftentimes new networks have to promise
a certain amount of money to the cable
carriers in order to be on the line up
and if you don't have those assets it's
tough too tough to get on you know Paul
was a you know he's a great leader and
you know he had the skepticism of both
Republicans and Democrats and and if you
knew Paul it wasn't so much Democrats
that got him upset it was Republicans
and conservatives or Republicans who
pretended they were conservatives who
weren't acting conservatively so his
greatest ire often I found was directed
at alleged conservative elected
officials who weren't doing the right
thing here's another clip of another man
that you worked some with this is from
1999 this is the late reader vine this
is one of the biggest problems my
biggest objections is we have a very
corrupt administration in terms of the
administration of justice in this
country the Justice Department is
absolutely terrible
the FBI is terrible the only one I'd
like to get into that is a document that
but the news media lie down and take it
they're not they're not rising up and
saying this should be exposed we should
do something about this we should put
the heat on Janet Reno in fact she
should have been out of there a long
time ago
she's been an instructor of justice more
than she's been a facilitator of
investigations Reid was always upset
about something we saw a lot of him on
this network in the early days what you
learn from him you know one of my
favorite read quotes was a harmful truth
is better than a useful lie and this
town is it's so true we just town is so
full of useful lies that everything the
government does is on the up and up that
the FBI is somehow a different
government agency than the other
government bureaucracy is that everybody
in town complains about and you know
it's remarkable you know other than
inserting an attorney generals name
Lynch for Janet Reno there's nothing he
said that it wouldn't be applicable
today and I mean you need people on both
the conservative side and the left wing
side who don't don't drink from the
cooler the you know don't drink the
kool-aid and call it as they see it and
are honest about the analysis of the
problems here in Washington and
oftentimes I think you raise these
issues and people say well I agree with
you but it's not politically feasible to
address these issues and you know I
think the American people are tired of
this they're tired of being put off in
terms of dealing with the corruption of
Washington and the and the perception
that the Washington class the
politicians and bureaucrats are
protected and not subject to the same
rules and regulations and and
accountability that Americans typically
are we saw Rita Ryan who was always
upset about the media is called most
immediate left-wing we saw Paul Wyrick
as you well know created national power
television because he thought the media
was too liberal but here you are on this
program in 2009 talking about to me and
I've heard you say something similar to
this recently let's watch you I think
the media really loves what we do
because I can't tell you how many
reporters I've talked to who have four
requests pending but they're not they're
never going to an answer from the
government
and their media organizations don't have
the resources to litigate but what we do
why do you why do you think favorably of
the media and why do you have the
resources in the media doesn't that was
back in 2009 as a long time ago yeah I
think it's a visit you know the business
of the media has changed there's not
much in the way or less of investigative
reporting you know they think that media
values judicial watch because we get
documents out I mean you may do it you
may just agree with how we read them but
in the end you can look at them
yourselves you can interpret the Clinton
Foundation emails yourself because you
know look at them yourselves so that's
the wonderful thing about the Internet
is that you know that there's this
there's this accountability the media
that used to not to be there but you
know there is a - there is still bias in
the media there is a the reporters tend
to be ideologically liberal many of them
are able to put that aside in the
pursuit of a good story that's for sure
talk shows are way over on the right
well the talk shows are different than
you know the opinion culture is much
more favorable to conservatives than it
used to be I think that a reporting
culture is still institutionally left
and certainly at the editorial level I
mean not editorial in terms of opinion
editorials but editors they're just
hostile to conservatives I mean we we
sought and applied for consideration for
a Pulitzer Prize and we were told we
didn't meet the standards of journalism
and to me that was such an outrageous
insult given that the committee had
approved Pulitzer Prizes for nonprofits
who do the exact same type of work
Judicial Watch does which is get
documents and report on them how
surprised were you that you didn't get
consideration I was surprised that we
didn't get consideration I wasn't
surprised I wouldn't be surprised if we
could get a Pulitzer Prize but the idea
that we wouldn't even get past the door
shows you just what the attitude is in
the in establishment media towards the
hard-charging work we do are you going
to submit again well yeah I think so
sore loser I mean you have to submit
norther yeah I have no doubt our work is
Pulitzer Prize worthy in terms of the
public service we've brought forward to
the education of the public and the
investigative journalism we've done both
through our information Freedom of
Information Act requests and our
independent reporting on the border and
national security and things like that
it's a few media organizations have had
the impact historically as Judicial
Watch has had why do you think they
wouldn't look at you favourably cuz
they're liberals and they don't like
conservatives that simple no I think
it's that simple let me get to your book
page 148 the headline on this particular
chapter is Congress claims it's a small
business that's a classic and it's a
classic of Republican corruption working
in league with President Obama so the
law was passed in a way the Obama care
law was passed that present that that
Congress supposedly was not going to be
exempt from Obamacare and had to
participate in Obamacare and the problem
was that for Congress to participate in
Obamacare they would have had to join a
large plan health care exchange well
there were no at-large plan health care
exchanges there were only small business
exchanges those wouldn't come into being
there'd be no exchange they could
participate under law until 2017 so they
had the part so they pretended they were
a small business exchange and they're
participating in the DC government small
business exchange and so employees are
getting illicit benefits because they're
getting pre tax subsidy for their health
care insurance that wouldn't be
available anyone else in a large
business seeking to participate in a
small business exchange dad-dad less
than 50 employees yes and they certified
we found through the Freedom of
Information Act from the District of
Columbia government they certified that
there were less than 50 employees that
they lied it was fraud anybody covered
this we've covered it there's a media
that have been covering it David Carr
senator vitter has been trying to push
for accountability there has been
by members of his own party so the whole
thing was created just so that they
wouldn't have to it was a so they can
participate with a square peg into a
round hole now this is what they should
have done they would have had to party
the under the law they would have had to
participate individually in an
individual health care exchange but they
would have lost the tax benefit of the
premium subsidy and paid a little bit
more for their insurance or you know
whatever the tax benefit would have been
they would have to pay directly out of
their pocket pre pre-tax so rather than
do that and there would be a haircut you
have to pay five six extra thousand
dollars a year they could have made that
up by increasing the salaries of
employees or members but that's not
politically feasible evidently so they
work with President Obama's
administration to pretend that Congress
was a small business exchange and so
right now there are senators and members
of Congress who are fraudulently getting
tax benefits they're not do under the
law and a bunch of their staff are and
for reasons that I think are quite
obvious you raise this with leadership
and they have zero interest in
addressing the lawlessness and this is
something they can stop immediately just
simply through an HR practice and rule
you write about inspectors general this
is what you say stirring words but
equally stirring were the words of the
forty-seven out of 73 independent
inspectors general who wrote to Congress
just the day after Biden's speech to
emphasize the importance of quote the
principle that an Inspector General must
have complete unfiltered and timely
access to all information and materials
available to the agency that relate to
the Inspector General's oversight
activities without unreasonable
administrative burdens a lot of words
what's in it and I want to also ask you
why during mrs. Clinton the secretary of
state time for years there was no
Inspector General appointed and I read
somewhere that it was the first time in
night since 1957 or something like that
that they hadn't through a whole
administration hadn't appointed a
permanent Inspector General you know we
noticed this in reporting for the first
book corruption chronicles which came
out 2012 which is the book two covers or
the first half of the Obama era that we
highlighted the failure to appoint the
inspectors
and when you have acting employees and
inspector-general positions they tend to
be more political and more sensitive to
the internal pressure because either
want the job full-time or so as a result
they tend to be more politically
friendly and we've seen scandal after
scandal where Inspector General's may
have been more collaborative with the
agency they were supposed to be
independently monitoring than they
should have been what kind of
independent power do they have or should
they have well you know the agencies are
probably required by law to to cooperate
with them and and most recently they've
been a big fight with the inspector
general I think of the Justice
Department where the Justice Department
the FBI are suggesting they don't have
to turn over everything they're supposed
to under law to the Inspector General's
but that all being said it's still the
government watching the government and
the inspector general process is often
results in a lot of good information
coming out these reports I think are
well worth following if you're a citizen
go to the OIG pages for the various
agencies and look at the reports media
sometimes does pick up on them but they
expose a lot of waste fraud and abuse
but a lot of these reports are both
expose and cover-ups at the same time
where they give you some information and
don't draw the conclusions or disclose
the information you think ought to be
disclosed or highlighted and I think
they are is careful and politicals even
even the most independent ones are
government officials that deserve some
skepticism one of the things you also
cover in your book is the Bill Clinton :
a traveling conflict of interest he sure
was
and we knew that was going to be the
case you know what because Democrats
were worried about it Republicans were
worried about it mr. Obama was worried
about it and it was contingent on mrs.
Clinton promising the vet mr. Clinton's
business dealings and speeches and being
transparent about the foundation and
their donors and making sure the awal
separation between the State Department
of the foundation all that was all of
those promises on those ethics were
contingent on something
on her being put into office and she got
into office immediately began violating
the rules and one of our key four is
that I think pressured the
administration finally to admit that the
Clintons had this separate email system
was asking for the vetting of mr.
Clinton's conflicts of interests and we
found that virtually every speech he
wanted to do was rubber stamped didn't
matter the foreign potentate it didn't
matter the corporation foreign or
domestic
there was nothing I think we found out
of the 215 speeches we looked at I think
there was one that was kicked back and
he made 48 million dollars in speaking
fees as best we can tell I went to his
personal coffers and to mrs. Clinton's
coffers while she was Secretary of State
it's just remarkable and Cheryl Mills
her chief of staff had worked at the
foundation negotiated the agreement and
then became involved in vetting the same
things vetting the agreements the ethics
issues related to the foundation and the
speaking fees on an agreement that she
had worked on and was prohibited from
being involved in due to Obama's ethics
rules why would and you list a whole
bunch of this and the money in it why
would somebody pay you Barclays Capital
Singapore 325 thousand and I'm sure the
the travel was all paid for in addition
to that Needham Partners South Africa
three hundred fifty thousand for Bill
Clinton to make a speech what are they
after
what's their and you you also list firms
like JP Morgan Barclays Merrill Lynch
PricewaterhouseCoopers Goldman Sachs
Vanguard Group Sweden's ABG Sunday
sundial Collier I mean I can go down the
list but there's well are they after for
that kind of money in the lease its
insurance for what the president's
President Clinton's wife is Secretary of
State likely to be the nominee and run
for president and a half a million
dollars for a major corporation is small
change for the potential benefit that
comes from being a friend of the
Clintons
and the Clintons defined friendship
quite literally as by the amount of
money
if the first president that I can
remember they got money for speaking was
Gerald Ford and I my big recollection is
I got something like $15,000 to speak
what happened where did it go from $15
on Reagan made two million to give two
speeches in Japan and that was pretty
controversial at the time yeah and this
President Clinton made tens of millions
of dollars I you know it's obvious
influence-peddling
I mean that's it's it's it may not be
said explicitly although the foundation
emails now that we've uncovered suggests
that it was more explicit then it was
publicly known but why who you know the
American people are not fooled by mr.
Clinton's speech making and speaking
fees the rate for which he was getting
you know his rates increased
tremendously as she would became
Secretary of State why else would they
give them money was it because they were
being charitable and they like mr.
Clinton and he had particular insights
that weren't available anywhere else you
know why would a foreign government why
would we allow foreign governments to
give money to the spouse of the
Secretary of State why did the State
Department allow that to occur
repeatedly
it's just remarkable that she was not
more discussed this is obviously not a
pro Clinton look we but this show and
another week with David Cay Johnston who
has written not a very friendly book
about Donald Trump and I want to run
just a clip of it for those out there
who are very much on the Clinton side to
know that we're trying to do both sides
on this but here's David Cay Johnston
used to work for the New York Times
Donald does not understand the powers
limits and duties of our president under
the Constitution he talks like the
president is a dictator he you know
Hillary Clinton like John Kasich is
competent to be President she knows what
the job is and how to do it I I don't
see any cash and she's gonna pursue
policies that are inimical to the
long-term interests of the country he
tells us in the interview he's a
Republican do you think she is
competent
to be president and do you think he's
confident III think I think her interest
tend to be about consolidating power and
whether that leads the lawlessness I
think there's evidence that it does it's
Donald Trump compliment to be President
I think the presidency is overrated in
terms of I don't know what the standards
are to be President I mean President
Obama his his background was woefully
deficient for by any any normal standard
for presidency he was a state
legislature been a senator for a minute
and a half and became president of the
United States and you know I think even
his enemies would admit that he's
competence was not much in the way of a
problem for mr. Obama I think it was
decision-making was poor and his
approach to his pay you know talk about
a president who had a problem with the
constraints put on him by the
Constitution or didn't see those
constraints as a problem at all that he
just bursts through them all the time
but I think you know I think that's a
challenge for to be fair to either I
think the Obama legacy is going to be
continued to present a challenge to our
Republican former government because any
president Republican or Democrat is
going to have Obama as a precedent for
things they do and so you know if you're
a Democrat you could have a Republican
come in who does things outside the law
or outside the limits placed on him by
the Constitution and vice-versa for a
Democrat and so I know on the IRS I mean
that's a that's a no that's kind of an
interesting case we talked a lot about
the Obama IRS scandal in our book but
you know you have the Left concerned
about Trump and the IRS and you have the
right concerned about Clinton in the IRS
and thank you President Obama for making
that another threat that the Americans
have to worry about as the IRS come
after you and almost no we were oh well
they did during the Clinton years but
not how they audited us continued into
the Bush administration ironically but
they told us IRS officials what you
expect when you do the president you're
going to scrutinize the government the
government's going to scrutinize you so
the suppression of the Tea Party and the
outrageousness there was no surprise
when it was uncovered by a you know when
it was finally uncovered we're talking
about a burden go back to the fact that
she worked as an assistant to Hillary
Clinton at the State Department at the
same time she was on the payroll of
Tamayo which is run by Doug Bandar used
to be the top aide to Bill Clinton after
the presidency and she was also on the
foundation the Clinton Foundation
payroll how is that legal it shouldn't
have been it's not legal not you know
special government employee typically is
reserved for someone whose work is
really not capable of being done by a
current government employee you know the
head of GE is given a dollar a year to
come in and help you know build a plant
that's been blown up or you've had
certain czars appointed like the
compensations are after 9/11 I think he
was a that type of special government
employees there temporarily he's not
leaving his private-sector job coming in
doing a distinct job because it was in
to you inherent unique expertise and in
the case of you ma padeen obviously
deputy chief of staff position didn't
need to be filled by a special
government employee and when she was
pushed we found in the documents for
financial records she questioned why am
I being asked here this is the same job
as I'm always that I'm doing now I'm not
gonna change which is completely illegal
you're it's supposed to be a job that's
not capable of being done by the
government and it was the documents show
patronage position given the mrs.
Aberdeen in violation of the law can the
Congress and people who work in Congress
can they have another job outside I
think they're outside income is limited
to 20,000 dollars at least members what
about people that work in the White
House can they have an outside job i I
don't think so I think typically you to
degree you have outside employment it's
got to be vetted
or you know unless you're a special
government employee that's the type of
that's that's what those are scenarios
and there aren't terribly many of them I
think in the State Department there were
only a hundred or so the back a couple
of weeks ago in salon.com which I'm sure
you've read and know about I want my
name Heather Digby Parton wrote a piece
about Judicial Watch and I want to read
a paragraph and have you respond to it
considering the outcomes of the IRS and
the Benghazi scandals in quote it would
behoove the press to show a little
skepticism the history of this group
meaning Judicial Watch is very clear the
first time it weighs its campaign of
character assassination against Bill and
Hillary Clinton it's perhaps
understandable that the press failed to
recognize that they were being
manipulated by political operatives the
trumped-up Obama scandals added up to
nothing as well there was no excuse for
the media to fall for it again is
justice partisan hackery
you know the criminal investigation is
that the Clintons in the 1990s he was
disbarred found to have lied and
obstructed justice he was impeached mrs.
Clinton came this close to being
indicted
they've been new Criminal Investigations
new disclosures on Benghazi that show
that well we abandoned our troops we
exposed the fact that the White House
was behind the Benghazi lies who let the
creation of a select committee these
disclosures by the Clinton emails by us
has led to editorial led to the Clintons
running away from their own foundation
or at least pretending to and and
editorials even in the New York Times
this week telling on the Clintons that
pull out you know they're just they're
released there are hacks who write on
who write and are supporting evident you
know just don't like their guy or gal
being attacked and so the facts are
inconsequential to them in your
Wikipedia site there's a sentence or two
I want you to see if you can fill in the
blanks in July 2013 fitna was identified
as a key member of the grounds of
groundswell and
a secretive coalition of right-wing
activists and journalists attempting to
make radical political change behind the
scenes whose members met in the offices
of Judicial Watch well if you know it's
a private meeting and private meetings
are still allowed the United States of
America we the groundswell is the
meeting that is a private meeting that
left has all the time and I find it
interesting every time you have a
meeting with someone it's secretive it's
just crazy and we were a private group
were allowed to meet with our friends
and allies and and talk about what's
going on in the world the names that
I've I'd listen to a little bit of audio
from somebody had a an audio recorder in
one of these meetings yeah
did you never find out it was in
retrospect I could maybe identify the
person but I don't know who the person
literally was but people there like
Jenny Thomas - Thomas's wife was on the
line and tom Fitton you it was your
office Mike Flynn the general Steve
Bannon who is now running the Trump
campaign again Outsiders looking in say
that's all a part of the system there
they're all in bed together well I can't
tell you who's you know because there's
a private group and I'm not gonna go
around telling people who the members
are you know I write our column is
published up right Bart I've known badan
for a long time and you know good for
him that he was elevated to this
position you what grade would you give
him for his ability to run the Trump
campaign you know I'm not a political
guy that's contrary to what the left
might think I I don't know much about
campaigns I don't know how they're run
you know that's not our bailiwick I'm
not a lawyer either
at the end of your book we're just we're
just question we just ask questions and
we our lawyers think of ways to get
information and figure out how can we
hold this government to account and I
leave the campaigning to others and I
don't control campaigns I don't control
the timing of you know people think we
release documents but impact campaigns
we just release them when we get them
and when we can get them out
it's it's much more straightforward than
than you might think at the end of your
book you say this well we are a
conservative organization that believes
in the Constitution the rule of law we
are strictly nonpartisan and our record
shows it sure does what's the difference
between being a conservative
organization a nonpartisan and your
501c3 which means you can or can't Lobby
can or can't oh I take your baton you
have to lobby in the legal sense of the
term but to a minor extent and I try not
to get involved on the hill since most
legislations terrible and so yeah it's a
waste of time in my view how long will
you keep doing this oh I don't see you
ever stopping I mean well I'm probably
be working well for many many years I've
been that Judicial Watch for 18 years
now government corruption is going away
I mean I think we're in a crisis you
know Congress is spending four trillion
dollars plus a year is at the budget the
agencies don't want to tell you what
they're up to we have a president an
outgoing president who thinks the rule
law doesn't apply and it's catch me if
you can presidency you know well if you
don't like what I'm doing sue me and see
what happens one last question what are
the chances that you're 25 questions for
discovery to Hillary Clinton will be
answered in the 30 days that's required
oh I think they're high I don't think
mrs. Clinton's gonna she may object to
some of the questions you know that's
what lawyers do what she has worst it's
they reset the clock if she objects I
don't think so I don't think they're
gonna she's going to delay the response
to these questions I just don't think
that's going to happen
she's been when the courts asked for
material she's responded relatively
quickly and directly and I don't think
she's going to play games she you know
mrs. Clinton understands what it's like
before federal court and she's been
trying to be responsive to the court I
don't think responsive enough forthright
enough but
obviously we don't share her views on
her email usage so it's no surprise that
I'm not terribly thrilled with her
behavior tom Fitton runs judicial watch
this book is called clean house